font le succès incroyable maintenant
d'un livre sorti il ya une semaine à
peine et qui est déjà épuisé il s'agit
des histoires inédites du petit nicolas
de sempé et goscinny
il s'est vendu près de 70 mille livres
en quelques jours
marianne bonhomme et frédéric bazille
ont accompagné hier dans une grande
surface
sempé et anne goscinny la fille de rené
goscinny qui allaient à la rencontre de
lecteurs et lectrices ont de la chance
le magasin a gardé quelques exemplaires
des inédits du petit nicolas
presque plus fort qu harry potter
deuxième meilleure vente de la semaine
juste derrière le best seller da vinci
code
les 73 mille exemplaires du premier
tirage se sont arrachés dès les premiers
jours les gens demandaient les histoires
du petit nicolas
les inédits en premier mais quand on
leur disait qu'on en avait plus samedi
soir et prenez les autres formats les
mêmes thèmes qui ont fait le succès du
film les choristes le passé l'enfance et
en plus il ya un humour sur le scolaire
il ya un humour sur la vie de famille
qui est extraordinaire créé en 1959 paru
dans sud ouest et dans pilote le petit
nicolas a été vendu à 8 millions
d'exemplaires traduit en 30 langues
sempé le dessinateur et anne goscinny la
fille de l'auteur se réjouissent
aujourd'hui
j'ai pas vraiment surprise et puis je
crois que
quand on parle de mon père et son père
oui on peut s'attendre à un succès le
petit nicolas on se transmet de
génération en génération comme un
précieux héritage ma première fille qui
a déjà 28 ans donc je lui ai fait
apprécier la dore il faudra attendre le
23 octobre pour retrouver le livre dans
les rayons cent cinquante mille
exemplaires sont en cours de
réimpression